and uh a little earlier i spoke to our
security and defense analyst michael
clark and began by asking him how
significant the increasing russian
control of severo donetsk is
i mean yesterday it was just a sliver to
the east this morning it was 50 percent
there's the governor now saying well
it's three quarters we've got to assume
that in sweden the russians will take it
because it's the essence of luhansk for
them it's one of the two oblasts that
they want it's the smaller of the two
donetsk is bigger but they have to get
very donetsk if they're going to say
that we've got the hands if we look at
it in a bit more detail it's very
donetsk it's pretty clear to me that the
ukrainians are with i think that we're
drawing probably in good order they're
crossing the river the cevasco donette
river is a pretty big
uh feature it's important in in warfare
and i think that ukrainians are probably
withdrawing to leshyshansk
which is a more defensible area it will
allow them to slow the russian advance
down they hope uh the bridges are by and
large are down so they may not be able
to take much of their equipment with
them heavy equipment but i think that
they are generally speaking with drawing
the question then is
do they try and go all the way back to
slaving ants and kramatorsk which are
the two cities that control the rest of
the donbass they can certainly defend
them or do they actually try and go
toe-to-toe and fight for every bit of
territory between uh alicia and kramatos
but you think the ukrainian forces will
move back intact largely or as they are
currently formed at the moment the
russians because they take an objective
and then they don't keep going one of
the things that militaries learn is when
you take an objective you keep going if
you've got the opposition on balance
then keep them on balance and every time
the russians seem to allow the
ukrainians to withdraw in good order
reorganize themselves rethink so they're
giving them quite a lot of space to
actually reorganize that i suspect is
what they're doing here as well and if
we can go up further north to kharkiv uh
where we were recently um there seems to
be more fighting there now doesn't there
yeah well yeah i mean you were there i
mean khaki was the second city very
important i mean the ukrainians won the
battle of kiev the capital they won the
battle of kharkiv and what they did is
that they advanced to the northeast of
kharkiv they actually took
russian artillery out of range of the
city which is a great relief to the city
but they also cut
russian communication lines the easy
communication between belgorod over in
the on the russian side of the border
and israel down in the south here they
made the russians push eastwards where
the communication lines are not so good
i think that they've run out of steam
now i think the ukrainian offensive is
probably coming up against dug in
russian positions i wouldn't expect any
great movement there for the future but
ukraine has done well simply to relieve
kharkiv so where is their ukrainian
movement on the offensive down in curson
we were talking you've been talking in
the last you know couple of days about
the ukrainians moving into there we are
cursed
um
which is russian held obviously yeah i
mean how much progress in truth are the
ukrainians making this is the big battle
to come the the russians were pushing
southwards as if they wanted to attack
mikalaya from the south along the river
delta there um but the ukrainians have
had a really big counter-attack they've
got about four brigades in this drawn
from the territorial forces the marines
couple of reserve brigades but they're
obviously pretty good and they've really
pushed the russians hard to the
northeast of kershaw now the ukrainians
are saying we think we can liberate
kershaw not sure about that that's a
pretty big ask and if they did it would
be a big blow to the russians because
this is the biggest city the russians
have have occupied but if they lost it
even temporarily that'd be pretty big
this battle has been building for a
couple of weeks it probably hasn't
reached its peak yet but i suspect that
in the next week it may well just
finally then is it now a matter of for
the ukrainians of getting
bigger weapons in quickly
from
the from the west i mean this is partly
all about giving the russians something
else to worry about to take maybe a bit
of pressure off the donbass because the
russians have put so much into the
donbass the job for the ukrainians now
is they've got to hold on hold on for a
month for two months until the big stuff
really arrives in numbers it's on its
way
not as much as they want but if they can
hold then the situation will get better
for them the balance will tip their in
their favor during the summer but
they've got to hold for now but that's
taking its time what because of
political reasons or just logistical
reasons for very political reasons in
germany the americans have sent 90 m
triple seven howitzers very very useful
they probably need to send more
these sort of campaigns they just use up
equipment they burn it up within days
and that's the problem is that you can
send as much as you like they'll always
want more and the russians are very
they've got enormous amounts of
equipment it's not always good but
they've got lots of it so the ukrainians
will always need more as much as the
west can give them